[Aplausos]
este lunes la nave espacial Dark
colisionó a una velocidad hipersónica
con el asteroide dimorfos generando
Euforia entre los científicos la prueba
fue espectacular fue realmente todo lo
que esperábamos e incluso Honestamente
más estábamos sentados viendo cómo
llegaban estas imágenes a medida que nos
acercábamos más y más a dimorfos darte
fue lanzada el 24 de noviembre de 2021
con el objetivo de chocar con dimorfos
un objeto de 160 metros de diámetro
situado a 11 millones de kilómetros de
la tierra
gimorfos orbital alrededor de otro
asteroide dijimos Casi cinco veces más
grande la semana pasada los científicos
de la misión confirmaron que otro
dispositivo que acompañaba a Darth
conocido como Lisa cube se encargará de
mandar fotos del impacto de vuelta a la
tierra podríamos ver algunas imágenes
del conjunto de cubos que podemos ir
hace unos 15 días ya debería haber
volado y tomado algunas imágenes del
impacto que creamos luego en los
próximos meses vamos a ver más
información del equipo de investigación
sobre el cambio de dirección que
realmente hicimos el propósito de los
próximos meses es de evaluar el impacto
de la colisión para saber si se pudo
desviar la trayectoria del asteroide
según lo esperado jimorfos no representa
ninguna amenaza para la tierra Pero
según los astrónomos existen alrededor
de 25.000 asteroides lo suficientemente
grandes para provocar una devastación a
nivel regional y apenas el 40% ha sido
descubierto hasta ahora por lo tanto es
necesario de crear un sistema de defensa
Planetario que pueda desviar un
potencial objeto espacial que se dirige
hacia nosotros